click and white à madame arlette
grosskot un merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie
les décisions de la bce ont déçu celle
de la fed qui devrait être annoncée
incessamment continue à alimenter les
débats mais la majorité des analystes
parlent d'un relèvement des taux
d'intérêt face à un marché qui reste
fébrile ce nouveau trend aurait des
répercussions sur l'ensemble des places
boursières
non seulement sur celles des pays
émergents mais aussi sur la zone euro
longue de choc et redouté de plus en
plus d'acteurs économiques pointent du
doigt les carences des politiques
monétaires actuelles quand bien même
certains indicateurs apparaissent
positif baisse de l'euro baisse du prix
des matières premières les turbulences
de l'économie mondiale prête plus à la
défiance qu'à la confiance eu égard à de
nombreux paramètres d'un tel
incertitudes tels que les attaques
terroristes l'attention la tentation du
break site où la montée des extrêmes
tout ceci ajoute de l'instabilité à une
reprise timide la banque de france
prévoit d'ailleurs une baisse de 500
millions du pib au quatrième trimestre
par rapport aux prévisions
les bourses européennes font du yoyo
nonobstant l'annnonce du programme de
quantitative easing de la bce selon son
président la politique de la bce ne sera
efficiente uniquement si elle est
accompagnée de politiques structurelles
efficace domaines dans lesquels seuls
les gouvernements nationaux ont la
capacité d'agir pour ce qui concerne la
france la commission européenne souligne
que nos réformes manque d'ambition et
que la consolidation budgétaire reste
des plus précaires attendre 2020 pour
doper le pipe de 0 4% grâce aux actions
combinées du séisme et du pack de
responsabilité à tout le moins manque
d'audace
nous sommes donc dans l'impérieuse
nécessité de créer davantage de
croissance
que comptez-vous faire à court terme
pour y parvenir que ferez vous un en cas
d'augmentation des taux et plus
généralement quel est votre plan
d'urgence pour l'emploi
merci merci madame grosse cote
la parole